[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mais si un mini chers collègues
la nationalisation annoncée d'edf aussi
tonitruante soit elle ne répond pas aux
difficultés du groupe la première
difficulté financière c'est le mur
d'investissements rêver d'une dette de
43 milliard d'euros le groupe a perdu 18
milliard avec la corrosion sous
contrainte 10 milliards avec leurs
éléments de la reine en par l edf doit
s'engager dans des investissements
colossaux 65 milliard pour le grand
carénage 90 milliards pour les
européennes le deuxième enjeu est
juridique c'est l'articulation avec le
droit européen les concessions
hydroélectriques sont sous le coup d'un
différend vieux de 20 ans avec la
commission européenne quarantaine sont
arrivés à échéance et que dire du
principe du coût marginal qui lie le
prix de l'électricité à celui du gaz
c'est un désavantage pour notre mix le
dernier problème et stratégique c'est
l'absence de cap ne sont toujours pas
quelle est la politique énergétique du
gouvernement il souhaite une
nationalisation une relance du nucléaire
aujourd'hui mais il a arrêté la centrale
de fessenheim en 2020 un tel projet
astrid en 2019 quant aux concessions
hydroélectriques on a évoqué tout et son
contraire d'un côté on parler
d'ouverture de recrutement de quasi
régie que d'indécision que deux
revirements que de retard aussi ma
question est simple au delà de
l'association comment comptez-vous
résoudre des difficultés d'edf qui met
en péril notre souveraineté